[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAT STEELE: All right.
Good morning, everyone.
Welcome to the last day of Next.
Thanks for joining us
for the Dev109 session
on accelerating time to market
with APIs and microservices.
Cool.
So I'm Matt Steele.
I'm a digital engagement
lead with Google Cloud.
And I'm going to kick
off this session.
I know you really want to hear
from our friends at Equifax.
David Stephens, who
heads up architecture,
is going to do discuss
their API journey.
And finally, we
have an awesome demo
by Dharmendra, who
goes by DP, and he's
going to show the new Equifax
developer experience that
launched a few weeks ago.
So I live in Mobile,
Alabama, which
is pretty far from just about
every Google office and most
of our large customer sites.
I travel almost
every week for work
to meet prospects and customers,
and when I start each week,
I'm sitting on an airplane
at the end of a runway.
And acceleration is
extremely important for me
to get to where I need to be.
So why is acceleration
important to enterprise IT
and the business?
After years of
experimentation, Agile
has finally gone mainstream.
Companies inside and
outside Silicon Valley
are using some form
of this methodology
in their software
development lifecycle
to enable rapid building and
frequent delivery of software
updates with
continuous integration.
Under this approach,
companies are
seeing increased productivity
within their AppDev teams,
faster release of
digital products,
and improved
customer experiences,
all with reduced cycle times
and improved productivity.
So how are microservices
revolutionizing
app development?
Along with the rise of
cloud computing and Agile,
the increasing use
of microservices
has profoundly affected how
enterprises develop software.
Microservices enable
businesses to innovate faster.
Development teams
can independently
develop, deploy,
and scale components
of large applications.
The adoption of cloud
containers and CI/CD tools
has made microservices
implementations much easier,
leading to more and more
modern software being built
as a set of microservices.
App development teams
implement microservices
using a variety of stacks like
Kubernetes and Netflix OSS,
depending on their needs.
And all of these
microservices use web APIs
as a mechanism to
communicate with one another.
So both the concept of an API
and the concept of microservice
involve structure and
interactions of software.
A microservice can
be misconstrued
as simply an end point
to provide an API,
but microservices have much more
flexibility and capabilities
than that.
An easy way to
think about an API
is it's basically a contract
of actions you can request
for a particular service.
APIs are in use
today in a multitude
of web apps such as social
media, banking, telco,
health care, and many more.
The standardized contract
allows for external apps
to interface with one another.
In today's world eight
codes are usually
developed using RESTful style.
These APIs have
a series of verbs
associated with HTTP actions
like get, post, and put.
So the Apigee API platform
enables enterprises
to accelerate innovation,
provide shared services
and data, and adapt to
market and customer needs.
APIs have become the foundation
of that fast-moving digital
economy.
As customer
expectations increase,
companies need to
be able to meet
those demands with flexible
and scalable technology.
Apigee applies security and
traffic management policies
and routes requests
to microservices
while orchestrating your legacy
services and monolith apps.
So I'd like to introduce
you to David Stephens, who's
going to speak to you
about how he and his team
are accelerating
time-to-market with API
and microservices at Equifax.
DAVID STEPHENS: Thank you, Matt.
MAT STEELE: Sure.
Thanks.
DAVID STEPHENS: Good
morning, everyone.
If you're like
me, it's Thursday.
It's been a long week.
We're all starting
to get little tired,
so feel free to
kick back, relax,
fall asleep, don't listen to
anything we're about to say.
If you are from
Equifax, I would try
to get you to go ahead and
leave so DP and I aren't
subject to instant
and infinite ridicule,
but I don't think
I'll get any takers.
So I am the chief
architect for Equifax.
What that means
is that I actually
work with a globally-dispersed
team of architects
who are all experts in variety
of disciplines who are working
to define where we're
going, what we're
doing, how we're
doing it, and build
the Equifax of the future.
So while we talk about
the Equifax of the future
is because we have, well,
the Equifax of yesterday.
We're in the middle
of a transformation.
The Equifax of yesterday is an
amazing company, very large,
a lot larger than people think,
with multiple business units
doing lots of different
things around the world,
and they've been doing
it for over 100 years.
So certainly over the last
20, 30 years as technology
has really become commonplace
in fintech industries--
they've done it,
we've done it, Equifax
has done it the same exact
way that most fintechs have.
Sorry.
I've got a white line
here I can't cross,
and what does that mean?
Well, we've got a
lot of mainframes.
We've got lots of
database systems.
We have lots of
custom-built systems.
We have lots and lots
and lots of data centers.
We have tons of
redundancy in how
things are built,
what's being built,
what capabilities
are being driven.
We've got amazing engineers
working around the world,
all working on roughly the
same thing at the same time
in some places.
And they're doing
it in an approach
that twelfths adds to that.
It takes time.
It's we've introduced
latency with our legacy
within our development
methodologies
and processes because
of the complexity
and the complications that
we have within our scale.
So that starts to
drive us to where
we are today with the
transformation that we're on.
Certainly folks know
Equifax has had some fun
over the last couple of years.
Within that, we've been driving
a lot of transformation,
investing a tremendous amount
of time, money, effort, energy
into that transformation,
starting with security
hardening, making sure with
this vast array of systems
that we have, are we
doing the right things
at the right time
in the right place?
Do we have the right controls?
And, of course, we do.
Well, we've got a powerful team
that's working through that.
At the same time we're
doing that, we're
starting to start to
revamp our systems
and how we're
approaching those things.
And so we started, I don't
know, roughly about a year
ago with, what's the next
stage of our technology
transformation?
How do we take all
of these things
and do something a
little bit different,
flip each one of these
things on their head?
Custom assembled,
not custom built.
Common technology stacks not
disparate technology stacks.
Well-documented and
discoverable services available
in a self-service model,
rapid onboarding of customers
and consumers--
weeks, minutes, hours, not
days, months, and years.
Highly agile,
adaptable work streams,
and a constantly
evolving capability that
doesn't necessarily require
our consumers and customers
to constantly evolve
with us, but they
can adopt as they need to.
We want to enable, not
disrupt our customers.
But at the same time, we
need to give them more, give
our consumers more, on
a minute-by-minute basis
and not say, oh,
you've got to wait
six months to get something.
And so, there's a lot
of aspects to that.
So we sat down, and
the first thing we did
is developed an idea of
a microservices-based
architecture.
We have a lot of
commonality around the globe
of how we do things.
And so we said, well, let's
break those capabilities
into discrete microservice--
you remember Matt's slide--
which we call our core
services framework.
It takes discrete
capabilities, moves those.
And then, how do
we then have those
be system-to-system
conversations as opposed
to human-to-system
conversations, et cetera?
And so we said,
OK, well, got it.
Microservices.
Perfect.
Makes sense.
Capabilities.
We aligned to those.
We have tons of them that
we're breaking into those.
We said, well, we've got to have
a way to connect all of that.
We've got to have a way
to implement that strategy
on a global scale and focus
on the capabilities that
drive that value.
How do we develop and deploy
those reusable microservices?
How do we let both internal
and external consumers--
meaning our dev teams, our
product groups, our product
alliances, our customers--
take those things,
stitch them together to
build the capabilities
that they need?
Do it without requiring tons
of customization of code
but really configurable
capabilities.
Create a consistent
experience across all that.
Simplify the formats.
Make data available whether
you want to consume it.
You might want to consume it.
You might not want
to consume it.
Do it all in a governed manner.
You can imagine, if any of are
in fintech, regulatory issues,
we've got them out the wazoo.
And so we have to
have systems that
allow for that discrete
management of those policies.
Reduce the response time.
So on getting data.
You think about your
stack that includes
13 hops to get to root
data and everything that
has to be done in-between.
You're talking about some
substantial transaction time.
So how do we reduce that?
How do we then also take
all of these things,
reduce the risk on our
back-end stability?
And how we do it with
security from the ground up,
built in, not bolted on?
So we turned all those
into requirements.
We said, OK, well, that's our
requirements for how we're
going to do this thing with APIs
and stitching our microservices
together so that
ultimately we can
reduce that time to integration,
improve our speed to market,
have that faster response time,
lower our maintenance cost,
have shorter feedback
loops, have more rapidly
available capabilities to the
marketplace, both internally
and externally, eating our
own dog food, if you will.
So we said, well,
OK, well, we've
got to create a framework
for our strategy.
We said, well, OK, first is
establish a digital strategy.
We've did that.
We aligned our
organization and culture.
So we were very, very monolithic
in our architecture and very
monolithic across
multiple monoliths,
if you will, in the way our
technology teams organize.
We said, you know what?
If we're going to go with a--
instead of following Conway,
we're going to beat him
over the head a little bit
and say, listen.
If we're going to build
this around microservices,
let's build our teams
and dedicate teams
to owning and building
those microservices,
build it, own it, operate
it, run true SRE model
for everything we're doing.
Total culture shift
for the company.
Which, of course, you can't
just replace a culture.
You have to guide
it and transform it
and tweak it and move it along.
So that became part
of our strategy.
We had to go out and look and
evaluate and build or deploy
supporting technologies--
GCP, other cloud providers
who will go unnamed.
The tools that they provide,
whether they're managed
services, whether they're
capabilities where
they're simply run,
infrastructure-as-a-service
type things.
And then we had to engage
our partner ecosystem
to make sure that we're
doing the right thing
and learn from each other.
We're learning
from our customers.
Our customers are
learning from us.
We're learning
from our partners.
Our partners are
learning from us.
We have Google teams deep in
the bowels of the company who
are embedded and helping
us do a lot of things.
One of those things being, of
course, implementing Apigee.
So that set up our
framework, set up our thing.
It says, OK, well, then
what is our strategy?
APIs everywhere.
APIs for everything.
Everything is API.
Even internally, we want to
ensure that this service is
talking to that service.
Everybody's use a common
logging, monitoring,
metering services.
Everybody's using a common this.
If you need this capability,
that service is discoverable.
The swaggers are out there.
You can grab it,
deploy it, run with it.
Internally open sourced.
So if you need to extend it, you
can extend it, govern it back
into the company, the team that
owns it, and do all of this
to--
basically, what it
says up there is
rapidly enable
those capabilities
and minimize the investment.
That's what all of our
CFOs are looking for.
So that's what
we're trying to do.
It's certainly what we want.
Makes our lives easier.
Improves our quality of life.
Improves our quality of
service to our customers.
Improves the quality of
service to our investors
and our partners.
Will drive high
levels of automation.
Be able to incorporate
more scope faster.
Be a lot more efficient
in how we're doing things.
Be able to personalize those
APIs through configuration.
Be able to adapt as you can,
as you want to, as a customer.
Adapt those changes or not.
Where are we?
Well, we started an API program.
We defined our
microservices architecture.
We started an API
program to work it.
We started a tribe.
You call it a center
of excellence here,
but internally, we
call them tribes--
if you're familiar
with Spotify model.
We started a tribe, just
actually defining those things.
We have a product alliance,
who owns the product aspect,
the external aspect of it.
We have an internal product
thing that is actually
defining, hey, you know what?
Development Team X, what do
you need out of our capability?
We started both internal
and partner APIs
so that we can start leveraging,
pushing those globally.
Went to centralized
governance of these things.
So instead of everybody getting
to do whatever they want,
whenever they want,
however they want, we said,
well, no, here's some
guardrails, principles.
We don't want to be
overly prescriptive,
but we also don't want
to be overly hands-off.
So you end up with sprawl
and disparate technologies
and right back to
the problem state
that we had in the first place.
So we said, let's not do that.
Let's actually have
some governance
around how these
things are done.
Went to drive the adoption
heavily through discovery.
Every tribe, every
microservice, has
a page in our service catalog
says, hey, here's what we do.
Here's who we are.
Here's who are support
infrastructure.
Here's who you call.
Here's who owns it.
Here's who designed it.
Here's the link to
the source code.
Here's the swagger.
Here's some example code.
Here's how you do this.
And that's internally.
Where are we on that journey?
Well we're down it.
I mean, we've got
a long way to go,
but that's what we're doing.
And we are making
strong headway in that,
and what that's helping
us do is actually define
that, OK, if we want
our customers to engage,
whether they're furnishing
data or consuming data from us,
we want them to engage the
same way as a partner ecosystem
within its developers.
So that's helping us
define the capabilities
and the requirements
that we need
and that we have around
our Gateway Platform.
Ultimately, that helps
us transform the customer
acquisition.
I think we're doing OK.
We've got some early stuff.
And DP's going to give us
a demo here in a short bit.
I think we're doing OK.
We've got the tribes,
rather, that are
in the product
alliances are really
starting to grasp onto it.
And it's a struggle
a little bit.
We've got to operate
the old, keep that
running while we build the new.
The new, we're not
really evolving code.
We're completely replacing it,
which makes for a lot of fun.
But it's going OK.
We're pretty excited about it.
There's a lot of folks in here
from the architecture team
and the technology
leadership team who
I wish weren't in the room.
But these are all
folks that are engaged
every minute of
every day in actually
making this come to life.
And the amount of passion
that we have in doing it
has been pretty amazing.
Because we're doing
this on a global scale.
a?
Lot of people
don't realize this.
You might all.
But a lot of people don't
realize that Equifax is not
just a US company.
We are global.
We're in 24 countries.
The credit industry
actually exists everywhere
in the world in some
form or fashion.
Sometimes it's positive.
Sometimes it's negative.
Sometimes just the
way those things work.
But it actually
exists everywhere,
and right now we're in
24 of those countries--
Middle East, Asia, North
America, South America,
Australia, and New
Zealand, Canada.
We're all over the place.
And we're doing things
beyond just credit reports.
We do business intelligence
and employment verification.
We do identity and
fraud services.
We're one of the largest holders
of identity in the world,
believe it or not.
We have 1.5 billion unique
or something like that.
I don't know if I put
somebody on the spot.
I think it's something
like 1.5 billion people
within our scope.
So we're providing
that on a global scale.
Well, so we needed
a solution, we
needed a platform that would
meet that global scale,
it would meet that
availability requirement
on providing access to
all of these services
and these capabilities,
providing access
to the data in a governed model.
And that's where we
settled on Apigee
and used that as the
core for our framework
and how we're producing those
services out to the market.
We're running that
all over the world.
We have multiple regions.
We're running it in
multiple providers.
We are fairly leaning
heavily towards the GCP
stack at this point.
If anybody read
our earnings call,
I think the most-used
word was Google.
But we have to be multi-cloud.
Certainly everybody
knows Apigee's--
where it came from.
We have a lot run on AWS.
We have a lot running here.
We have a lot running there.
And that's fine.
It adds some
complexity but makes
sure that we're actually
paying attention and doing
things the right way.
Because this is the
kind of stuff that we're
producing through it.
These are some of the
things I mentioned
that we have lots of
different types of clients
of our developer portal.
We have customers,
mobile, web, our service,
our internal services framework.
That's the bottom one
that got cut off there.
That's our internal
users of the same thing.
All going through
a gateway, which
is providing us governance,
authentication, analytics,
monetization, et cetera, in a
framework that is not custom
built. So everybody's
familiar with it
or can be easily
familiar with it.
And we're pushing our swaggers
out all over the place
so that people can get
it and actually onboard
onto the developer portal DP's
going to show you in a minute,
because we're providing
this type of stuff.
Like I mentioned, asset,
wealth, verification.
Did anybody know we do all these
things besides-- if you're not
at Equifax?
A lot of people think
we're just credit,
but we're so far beyond that.
And so we have to
be able to provide
for a robust methodology
to integrate.
Like I said, we're
down that journey.
We publicly launched
our dev portal--
DP, I don't know
how long ago it was.
But we're already onboarded a
number of customers into that.
They're starting to use it.
We're starting to see some
really great results out of it,
just as we are today.
We're reducing the design
of some of those APIs
from things that would
take months because we're
going a lot more discreet.
And we're doing this on a
microservices [INAUDIBLE]
we're down to a week.
We're reducing
that time-to-market
in a lot of cases.
We've got drastically
improved security.
We were already in good
shape, but it's bolted on.
Now we're doing
it, and it's just
inherent in what we're doing.
We're enabling our customers
who are self-service portal.
Big deal.
Love our customers.
Customers love us,
most of the time.
But they really are
starting-- especially
in the banking
industry-- they're
starting to move from being,
we'll never go onto the cloud,
to just like, hey, Equifax,
what are you doing?
Can you help us?
We're helping them
move down these paths.
And we have some banks
and some customers--
take the Credit Karmas
and the Cap Ones
and stuff-- that
are far beyond us,
and they're begging
us to move forward.
Well, this is us being
able to now start
to help them and do this
instead of a batch process
running over SFTP.
We're going API to API,
which drastically changes
the performance
and the interaction
that we have with them and,
ultimately, the satisfaction,
which is fantastic.
And then we're getting
a lot more visibility.
We're already start to see
and learn and discover things
about how we were doing those.
Looking forward,
we're releasing a lot
of industry-specific
product suites,
talent verification services
for human resources,
our government services
that are coming through,
our largest division, USIS,
opened up the data hub concept,
which is being able
to open up data
sources in a very
protected and regulated
manner to the outside world.
That, of course, you can imagine
has a lot of things around it.
But you know what?
Data exchange is what
the world's about.
So we are one of the
largest keepers of data.
We want to enable
the market to be
able to use that to
improve consumer life,
improve customer life, improve
business, improve whatever
your use case might be.
So I think with that, we'll
ask our Dharmendra, DP--
it's easier to say--
to come set up his
demo real quick.
And I think after that, we'll
take a couple of questions.
DHARMENDRA PARIHAR: Hey.
[INAUDIBLE] OK.
Send.
OK.
Yeah, thank you, David, and
good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Dharmendra Parihar.
I go by DP.
And I'm the digital
experience leader at Equifax.
I manage a team that manages
the API Gateway Platform,
and we build all the
products and solutions on it.
And just to give you
guys a background,
so we started this
whole API journey
almost three to four years back.
And it was last year under the
leadership of our CTO, Bryson,
we really accelerated
the program.
And we rolled out the
first beta version
of our developer portal.
So I'm going to show you what
we have built of our whole API
platform, the developer portal.
And for us, it has been
a real game-changer,
for us and our customers.
The way we can
integrate our customers
and integrate to our APIs, and
we can expose these APIs end
products to them was
a real game-changer.
So it was a win-win for
both us and our customers.
So I'm going to
go over the demo.
I'll show you the
whole portal and some
of the back-end
services that we have.
And we'll be taking questions
at the end of the session.
And so Matt told me there is
a Dory, online Dory, that you
guys can go in, and if
you have any questions,
you can post it there.
So our API portal, the
developer portal we call it,
is an interface to all
of our APIs end products
to all of our developers
and customers.
So if I'm going to go and jump
into that development portal
here, which is
developer.Equifax.com.
So that's our developer portal.
So traditionally, our
customers and business partners
and developers
typically get this URL
maybe from a sales contact
or business contact.
They might pass on this URL.
Developers will go in there
and check out this portal.
The other way is what
typically most of the people
do these days is just go to
Google and search for this.
So, me as a
developer, let's say I
go into one of the best search
engine, Google, out there.
And I look for, as
a developer, I want
to see what APIs Equifax has.
So you would just type
Equifax APIs and hit Enter.
So it's going to show
them our developer portal
right here on the first link.
You click on this.
This takes you to our portal.
So now, I, as a developer
is into the portal,
and I'm just looking through
the different sections here.
So you have all the
products that we
have listed, some documentation
here on how to get started,
and some information on
how you can contact us
in case you have any
issues or questions.
So since we have rolled
out the beta version,
we have a lot, lot
more products right now
that are being rolled
out to the portal.
For this beta version,
we have rolled out
a suite of InstaTouch
products that we have.
And InstaTouch is our--
it's a flagship, frictionless,
pre-fill consumer
authentication and
pre-fill solution.
So we can identify a
consumer purely based
on his device with
real-time integration
with our telecom partners
and Equifax data asset.
So you don't have to go through
this whole process of filling
up your entire information, your
name, address, other details,
verify your identity.
All this manual process
is completely eliminated.
It's just a few keystrokes,
seven keystrokes I believe
is all you--
some basic information we
need, and we can authenticate,
and we can pre-fill
all that information.
So it's a really cool product.
It goes by the name InstaTouch.
And InstaTouch ID is the product
that does the consumer identity
verification and pre-fill.
And then we have
additional products that
are built on top of InstaTouch.
Once we have verified
your identity,
we can provide you additional
Equifax data assets
like please in our first IP
where we can pull enough credit
card and then actually use that
to make a payment employment
your account on file
and that's like today.
So we have a lot of
these products that
are built on top of the ones the
preferred and authentication is
completed, we can provide you
additional Equifax data assets.
So let's say I, as a
developer, go in here,
and I click on this link to
learn more about this product.
It gives you an overview and
some benefits and details
around what the API does.
And at this point,
the developer really
wants to go and
dig into the APIs
because that's what
developer want.
Hey, show me the specifications,
the APIs, the request response.
So far the developer,
if he is really
interested in getting
into the specifications,
he has to sign into the portal.
So this is where
we have a link here
where the developer
can go in and register
for an account on
the developer portal.
And everything
here is self-serve.
The moment you go in here,
you fill in your information,
you accept the terms and
conditions, and you register,
you immediately get an
email notification saying,
hey, your account is created.
Verify your registration.
Create a password.
And you will have a
credentials created right away
to log into the portal.
So one thing I want
to mention here
is we have two forms
of registration.
One is an individual
registration,
and then we have
company registration.
And typically, we recommend
our partners and customers
and developers to
register as a company
because that gives you a
lot more benefit in terms
of once you have
a company account,
you can go and add
other developers
into your company subscription.
So you don't have to come to us.
You can just manage
your own account.
You can add more developers.
Any subscription that you
create, all your developers
in your company can share that.
So it's all
completely self-serve.
And we have a few
additional things
that come with a company
subscription, which
I'm going to show you.
But ideally, we recommend going
in and signing up as a company.
So once you have created
your credentials--
I'm going to log in to the
portal with my credentials
right now.
OK.
So once you are logged in,
it will show your name here,
and you can go back and
see the same products here.
I'm going to go back
to InstaTouch ID.
And now, I can actually
go in and click
on the technical specifications.
So here, once you come
in here, it actually
gives you the entire
API specifications
in a completely open API
specification format.
You can just click on this.
Developers can download
the API specifications.
They can play around with it.
On the left here, it
shows a list of APIs
that you need to call
for the authentication
and pre-fill
InstaTouch ID solution.
And a good thing here is
once you click on these APIs,
it's going to show the customer
or the developer pretty much
all the information that he
needs to pass to the API.
So it has all the details
around what goes in the request,
in the headers, the payload,
what kind of fields there are,
what type of field it is.
And it shows you
what the response
is going to look like, what
will come back from the API.
And on the right
here, it actually
shows you a sample
request and response also.
So a really cool feature
here on all these APIs
is a try-out link.
So I can just
click on this link,
and the developer can,
on this portal right
here, make-- an API call
to other back-end sandbox
environment and get
a response back.
So he can actually test
these APIs right here
from the browser, make a call
all the way to the Google
Apigee platform gateway into
the back-end target endpoint,
get a response back, and get
it back here on the browser.
So I'm going to show
you how to do that.
So once you go back to
the Getting Started,
there are a list of
things already listed
on how to go about
executing these APIs.
So the first thing we recommend,
or you actually have to do,
is subscribe to the
products, because there
are certain things that need
to be created before you
can make a call to these APIs.
So essentially what
happens is all these APIs
are protected by OAuth2
authorization tokens.
So you really need to have
an authorization token
before you can make an API
call to any of these products
that we have here.
So to get a token, you need
to subscribe to the product
and then generate a token.
So I'm going to go ahead
and click on the Subscribe,
and I already have
one subscription.
But I'm going to
create one more.
So if you just go in here,
click on Request Subscription,
you pick the products that
you want to subscribe to.
Let's say I'm going
to pick InstaTouch ID.
And you can pick more
than one products here.
So once you click Submit, at
this point, me as a developer
has already subscribed
to the product.
We actually have created a
subscription in a completely
self-serve model.
And the customer
or the developers
can actually click on
that subscription here.
This is the one that
just got created,
and it will actually show
them all the credentials that
are created for them to generate
a OAuth2 authorization token.
So now I go back, and I
want to go ahead and create
a token, OAuth token, that
I need for the API calls.
So I just click on
the token API call.
I want to just take
one of the existing.
So now here you can
actually do a try out.
You fill in your information.
The client ID and secret that
you created in the subscription
before.
Just put those values in here.
Make a call.
This goes to the back-end
system in real-time,
makes a call to the OAuth
authorization service,
and it will come
back with a token.
So this is the access
token that I've
got from the OAuth service.
Now I just take
this token, and I
can go ahead and make API
calls to any of these APIs.
So I'm going to show
you something else here.
So let me pull this
token API call.
OK.
I can make a call.
So this actually sends
you all the response back
from the sandbox environment.
So the developer actually
made our request,
sent it all the way
to the back-end,
and got a response back.
So what I'm going to show you
now is the back-end system.
So this is our Google
Apigee gateway,
and what I'm going to show you
is typically what happens is
when our customers are
testing these APIs,
either in the sandbox or
in a test environment,
[? non-production, ?] they have
a lot of these challenges where
they're having issues.
They want us to troubleshoot.
It has been very
challenging for us
to really troubleshoot
and figure out,
hey, well, looks like
we have given you
the right specifications,
but you're not
getting the right response.
So a really cool
feature that comes out
of the box-- and Apigee,
like David and Matt
mentioned, it has
a lot of things
that come with the platform.
But one of the cool things that
I want to show you is and that
has really helped us
in troubleshooting
our customers' issues real-time
through the gateway is--
it's called a trace
functionality.
So I'm going to go in here,
pull up the back-end API.
And I want to click on
the trace link here.
So when I say this
API and enable trace,
I can actually go
and start to trace.
So at this point, anything
that is coming to this sandbox
API is going to be recorded,
and it will actually
show me what's
happening or where it's
failing or is it successful.
So now I go back here and I'm
going to make the same API
call again from the browser.
So this time it should actually
show me the entire trace.
This is really cool
because what it
shows me here is this is
where the request came
into the back-end
Apigee gateway.
I can click on this.
It shows me all the headers
that came into the gateway.
If I go down, it shows
me the entire payload
that was sent from the
customer or the developer.
In this case, I was the
one who was actually
sending it from the browser.
Shows you all the data here.
And then it shows you
a list of policies.
So we have a lot of
security policies
that we execute
against these APIs.
So these are the policies.
It's showing me that it's
executing all the security
policies.
We have standard policies.
We have Spike Arrest, rate
monitoring, quarter APIs,
IP whitelisting, and
pretty much all these APIs.
And you can actually click
on these different policies.
You can get details
of how long it
took to execute these policies
if you want to go and tweak
these policies.
And then once a
policy are passed,
the request goes to the
back-end sandbox environment.
And this is where, again,
it shows the same thing.
It'll show you all the
headers and payload
that was sent to the back-end.
This is the response.
It shows you what came back
from the target endpoint, which
is a sandbox endpoint.
And then this is what is
the response that actually
sent back to the customer.
So it's going to show you
what response was sent back.
So this is really cool.
I mean, this, to me, I mean,
I really like this feature.
It gives you complete
insights into what's
happening when the APIs are
flowing through the platform.
You can trace
through everything,
tells you how much-- in
terms of performance,
it shows you how
long it's taking
to execute these policies
and then all the details
that you get with
that trace here.
And, in fact, I'm going
to go back and maybe
change the token here.
And so if I send this
request to the back-end,
it actually failed.
So I can go back here, and
I can look at the trace.
So if you see the trace
that I ran before,
passed all the checks
and went to the back-end
and came back with a response.
But here, just looking at this,
I know it failed right here.
I see this mark
here, and it says
that, hey, failed in the token,
authorization token validation.
So this has been really cool.
OK, so let me go
back and show you
another feature that we have
built for our customers is.
So our customers, once
they have tested their APIs
against the sandbox,
they have built
their client applications,
tested everything,
they are all good.
And they want us to promote
their subscription to the test
environment, [? test ?]
[? authentication. ?] All that
is completely self-serve.
They don't have to
reach out to us.
All they need to do is
they just go back here
into their subscription--
go into the company
subscription.
And creating the subscription
is the same process
that I showed you earlier.
All you need to do is go and
say, hey, request subscription.
Pick the products.
Create your subscription.
But here, once they have
created a subscription--
this is an existing
subscription I created--
they are in the
sandbox right now.
Once they have
tested, and they want
to promote their subscription
to the test, all they need to do
is just go in here
and click this button,
select it, few fields
of information here,
enter their IPs
for whitelisting,
and they submit the request.
That's it.
At this point, the Equifax
product team gets the request.
They approve it, and
the entire subscription
is now available in test for
them to do integration testing.
OK.
Let me show you--
since I was on the
back-end, I just
want to quickly show
you a few things here
that we really like with
Apigee platform is the reports.
So I'm going to go
back and show you
some of the reports that have
been really nice to look at,
which especially the
developer engagement.
So what this does is it actually
shows me a list of developers
and apps and how many
developers have registered,
how many apps they are building.
And these numbers were
really nice to look at.
We see lot of developers
are coming in.
They are trying these APIs.
They are building
their products.
So all that statistics,
I can pull right here.
So if I look at it,
we'd just rolled it out,
but I'm seeing that we
already have 1,334 developers.
179 applications have been
built from these developers.
And this is all from what date?
Just one day.
So this is the
kind of enablement
we are doing for our
customers and developers
where we are really seeing
people coming in and trying
these APIs, creating their apps.
Another cool thing that
you can see in the report
is the GeoMap.
This actually shows
you across the world
where all of our developers
are building these apps
and where all they're
accessing our applications.
So if I click on
United States, it
would actually even show me what
states they are coming from.
And I can go back
to a week, and I
can see that we have developers
all these different areas
coming in and building APIs or
applications against our APIs.
OK, so I think that is
all I had for the demo.
One thing I want
to say is so what
about I showed you in
the last 15 minutes
is where the developer comes
in, registers to the portal,
subscribes to an API, goes
through their documentation,
have all the specifications,
try these APIs out
against a live
sandbox environment,
and then create
their subscription
and push them to a
testing integration
environment and the
same process they
can even push it to production.
Showed you in 15
minutes what take us
weeks and weeks of manual
work, traditionally,
in the old legacy base.
And if not months, it would
take us weeks and weeks of work.
So this has really accelerated
and enabled our customers
to integrate with our APIs and
products much, much faster.
[MUSIC PLAYING]